the weather is absolutely incredible
today it's a summer day here in Los
Angeles
let's ride bikes
you
dragonoid beautiful day super windy
all showered I feel great
there's just something about being on a
bike that really helps me reset my
entire system
see right now I'm not training or
preparing for any competition any races
so I get to go out and just train every
day for nothing but the pure joy and
love of it and that's a really beautiful
thing and it really improves every
aspect of my life it helps me think more
clearly
asleep better I function more
efficiently during the day it does take
up a lot of time but I find that when
I'm training consistently regularly that
I actually work much more efficiently
and I end up getting way more done
check out this lake
people in boats on a lake in the middle
of Los Angeles in February that's pretty
awesome
the other day my gravelly voiced often
disheveled sometimes homeless often
tortured buddy Mishka subala came by the
studio to do the podcast if you're not
familiar with Mishka
he's writer he's an author he's an ultra
runner and ever since our first podcast
which was almost three years ago at this
point he's become a really good buddy
and he is also one of the most not the
most but one of the most popular gifts
I've ever had on the show we did the
podcast it was his seventh appearance on
the show which is unprecedented and a
little bit insane but not all went to
plan let me explain my idea was that I
would film the podcast share some
snippets a little behind the scenes to
give everybody a flavor of what went
down that's not quite what happened and
a lot of that is my fault
first I screwed up because I don't
really know how to use this camera very
well the stuff I film didn't really come
out that great it didn't cut together
properly and I forgot to turn the mic on
for significant portions of it but and
this is a very important but Mishka
hijacked my camera he started causing
all kinds of problems and the whole
project kind of went to [ __ ] because
that's what he does so I guess it's my
better judgment I'm gonna show you what
I did get but do me one favor when the
dust settles after watching this you
tell me should I still be friends with
this guy let me know in the comment
section below
and oh yeah if you want to listen to the
entire podcast conversation click on the
link is it here or up here I should know
that right
irrespective of my feelings about Mishka
at the moment and how difficult this guy
can be is pretty great
okay here we go you I will not be denied
hello my name is Mishka she Bali
I'm here to shamelessly promote there's
plenty there's enough time for
self-promotion I've all I do is provide
the Airways for you to promote your
stuff dude I I just thought that this
would give me an opportunity to be like
and so all that stuff that we talked
about in the podcast where you said you
feel weird about promoting yourself but
that was just nonsense or I hate it
this is rich roll I'm Mishka shoe
balling
we just did a podcast what did we talk
about uh we talked about the book how
important it is that everybody buys
right out of the gate we talked about
the universe man we talked about the
universe sending signs we talked about
sobriety we talked about the depravity
of alcohol addiction we talked about
faith actually we talked about your
resistance to face the difference
between being stubborn and being
determined we talked about jean shorts
yes you were calling them shorts which
is your part too which is it yeah
Jordans I think Majoris yes yeah this is
my it's my it's like the Fonz with his
leather jacket this is my uh but mostly
we talked about Michigan's new book it's
called I swear I'll make it up to you
here's what it looks like you guys it's
a beautifully written addiction memoir
that also is full of hope and redemption
I'm a sucker for a good addiction memoir
and this is one of the best that I read
and I think in the floor of though I
gave Mishka I said it's the kind of
addiction memoir that I wish I had
written
but know very well that I could not have
because Michigan is an extraordinary
writer any last words
thank you thank you peace he left me
alone in the office which is poor
judgment on his part of his part and so
we're gonna do a little beside but
behind beside the scenes behind the
scenes look at the the rich roll office
here these are a lot of the books that
he's pretended to have read the only
book that he has read this one called
finding ultra it's got all the merch the
plant Power Revolution
I think he's got stickers there can be
no revolution without stickers right I
think I think he has a weird spandex
fetish here's an Ultraman thing that's
obviously fake these are mics that he
doesn't know how to use another another
fake Ultraman thing a big stack of the
there's a hot wife Julie right Julie is
a babe seriously dude friends I really
did it was good it was I showed a side
of rich roll that the average listener
doesn't get to see it's time for you to
leave
seriously I got the stuff I gotta do I
gotta go I know more merchandising to be
done this is gonna be the lot this is
the last time the Alton you're gonna be
on the show I thought I'm waiting I
think I promise how do you make it so
hard it's what I do
all right dude get the hell out of here
how about I told you to leave go I'm
busy I can still take these books you
gave me right give those back
now seriously please shut the door
thank you never having me back I'm never
coming back then an artist of my caliber
should have to deal with like
unprofessional [ __ ] like that is
such a [ __ ] waste of time
it's a sham - I mean yeah everybody
knows that he's [ __ ] eating steaks
all the time I gotta call my agent and
just tell him that I'm not wasting my
time with [ __ ] amateurs like this
anymore I'm so far beyond this I'm a
[ __ ] a lister now I can't work under
these conditions I [ __ ] I run this
town
look at his shorts see that seriously
take yourself seriously